[Music]
[Applause]
my view
[Music]
s
that's what I'll give you to decide your
faith
[Music]
Roberto tell me what did you do back
home
oh
government work I'm retired man
I understand pain death for you holistic
because of these people I'm beginning to
understand real peace this is my wife
and I'm starting to believe
they see you as one of us now this is
where I'm supposed to be
what happens to you happens in many
towns
the mafia
there's like cancer
[Applause]
no cue
who said you could come here
you should stay out of other people's
business
whatever it is you and your friends do
do it somewhere else you warning me I'm
preparing
this goes to level four you will [__] on
yourself
[Applause]
seem like a man who understands violence
I like this place you can't take that
from me
I can take anything I want
police found multiple dead bodies on
that farm in Sicily if you kill him
[Music]
nine seconds
do I look like a killer
foreign
[Music]